Amniocentesis is a procedure
that lets doctors detect or rule out problems
with your baby's health
long before birth.
In the uterus
your baby is surrounded by amniotic fluid
that provides protection and nourishment.
Floating in the fluid
are cells from your baby
providing doctors
with genetic material for testing.
In amniocentesis,
your doctor will take a sample of this fluid
to test for specific genetic disorders
and birth defects.
Amniocentesis is usually done
in the second trimester of pregnancy
at 15 to 18 weeks.
It is generally offered to women
with certain risk factors:
--age 35 or older
which increases the risk
of chromosomal disorders
such as down syndrome.
--a previous child or pregnancy
with a birth defect
--blood test or ultrasound
suggesting a birth defect
such as down syndrome
or neural tube defects
--or a family history of genetic disorders
such as cystic fibrosis.
Amniocentesis may also be done
in the third trimester
for these reasons:
--to determine if the baby's lungs
are mature enough
should early delivery become necessary,
--to diagnose a uterine infection,
--or to check for anemia in a baby
with Rh incompatibility.
To begin your procedure,
your doctor would use ultrasound
to create an image of the fetus
and nearby structures on a computer screen.
Looking at this image,
the doctor can choose a safe place
to insert the needle.
Your doctor may give you an injection
of local anesthesia
to numb the surface of your abdomen
where the amniocentesis needle
is to be inserted.
Carefully watching the ultrasound monitor
to avoid contact
with the placenta or the baby,
your doctor will introduce the thin needle
through your abdominal wall
into your uterus
and into the amniotic sac.
He or she will then withdraw
a small sample of amniotic fluid,
remove the needle,
and cover the site with a bandage.
Your body will make additional fluid
to replace what was removed.
Your doctor
will continue to monitor the ultrasound
to check that the fetal heartbeat
is normal
and the baby tolerated the
procedure well.
You may feel mild cramping or pressure
in your lower abdomen
For about 24 hours after your procedure
you will be advised
to avoid physical stress
such as vigorous exercise,
lifting,
prolonged standing,
and sexual activity.